president biden is calling jerome powell
into his office the principal's office
for a meeting today we have some context
that we can provide here via a quote
president joe biden will hold a rare
oval office meeting on tuesday with
federal reserve chair jerome powell amid
the highest inflation in decades which
has angered americans and hurt his
standing with voters the two will
discuss the state of the american and
global economy according to a white
house statement it's the first meeting
between the two since biden in november
announced his intention to nominate
powell for a second term at the helm of
the u.s central bank according to a
record of the fed chief's public
schedule which is available through
march so why is he doing this well it's
pretty obvious inflation is really bad
in this country if you look at what's
happening just from a wage standpoint
wages have gone up but they have not
outpaced inflation and inflation
actually gave the average worker a 2.4
pay cut last year and if you look at
this in the context of global inflation
rates the u.s ain't doing so hot
australia is at 5.1 percent norway 5.4
sweden 6.4 all the way denmark canada
eurozone the us is at 8.3 percent just
slightly below the uk
and then we have the price index here
year over year we have now just seen the
first tick down right there on the
bottom right since november 20. but if
you look at the actual price index we
are at the highest level since 1982
we've seen 16 consecutive increases in
the inflation rate
inflation again is really bad and if you
look at this for a bunch of different uh
things like gas prices look at gas
prices the national average for gas
prices per gallon is up towards four
dollars and fifty cents per gallon we
haven't seen these numbers in a long
long long long long long time actually
never
california's record high gas prices
today 6.62 cents from scott budman a
year ago that price was four dollars and
16 cents and in some places gas has now
gone over seven dollars closing at seven
dollars and thirty cents per gallon food
at home is just as bad and we've also
seen house appreciation home price
appreciation versus inflation massively
outpaced look at this 130 percent over
inflation that is numbers that we have
never even seen close to right we got
close to those numbers somewhat i guess
99
in the 2008
housing crisis and then if you look at
this we're up over 130 now compared to
inflation rates from a house
appreciation standpoint so the economy
has gone bananas people are out of
control food is more expensive gas is
more expensive housing is more expensive
all these things around you are more
expensive so even with wages up slightly
over the last few years
it's not outpacing inflation it's gotten
really bad and why is president biden
doing this you have to think about the
incentives right midterm elections are
coming up it's obviously not good for a
sitting u.s president to have the
highest inflation that we've seen in 40
plus years and if you think about this
in context of what could happen he's
calling him in to determine what will
happen next right they're trying to
figure out what exactly to do so i think
that there's a bunch of different things
to be discussed here i'm sure that this
will be a somewhat contentious meeting i
don't think that anyone is uh arguing
that they are uh doing the right thing
to some instance they're putting in an
extremely difficult position now with
covet and now getting themselves out of
that we have
high inflation and now most people
believe that we are going into a slowing
or shrinking economy in a recession so
jerome powell president biden they're
both in difficult positions they're
calling a meeting to discuss this this
doesn't happen very often but i think
that there will probably be
some blame cast or some decisions to be
made around what will happen next what
is your your take away from this john i
love that quote call him into the
principal's office that's essentially
what's happening here right inflation is
here they can't hide it anymore it's
across the board on almost everything
you buy food at home food away from home
shelter literally anything that you do
it's more expensive now than it has been
in the past i think that jerome powell
um is being called into biden's office
essentially saying hey what the hell is
going on what are we gonna do to fix
this um and then this is gonna be a
caveat like do they do what they say
they're gonna do and what they say
they're going to do does it work right
so do we get to that point where it's
hey
look we're going to raise rates okay
does raising rates work or are we going
to still tank the economy i think it's
kind of just an overview um but yeah you
went through all the inflation numbers
8.3 inflation we're
we're one of the worst in the world to
be honest at this point we're definitely
like bottom 50 bottom 10 in the world uh
inflation europe just had really high
inflation numbers come out as well but
everything across the board is expensive
gas which is i believe what most
americans are probably thinking about as
some are coming up trips are coming up
seven dollars a gallon some places 662
in california that's insane it was four
dollars last year yeah i i think that
what we need to avoid though is pricing
all the blame on specific individuals
obviously these are the figureheads in
most cases they're uh either elected or
not elected depending on who we're
talking about in this situation but
ultimately it's it's impossible to tell
what would have been different if
someone else is in there the last two
administrations have printed a bunch of
money that's just a fact right and
they've injected a bunch of money into
the global economy and what we see now
is this massive influx of inflation at
the end of the day though what i think
is important to remember is everyone
just needs to look out for themselves
like we've talked about on the show for
a long time many many many other people
outside of mainstream media we saw them
spin the narrative for a long time that
it was transit it was non-existent it
was transferred then it was good for you
right and there have been many people
here on this show elsewhere that have
talked about inflation for a long time
now for over 12 months and said that not
only is it coming but it's going to be
really bad levels that we haven't seen
in decades and that's literally exactly
what happened so people can look at
bitcoin today and say oh it's not
inflation hedge that's not true right
bitcoin is up nearly 400 percent since
the since the pandemic started and
ultimately what it did was it front ran
inflation it saw all this money printed
going on it saw asset prices starting to
increase it knew that this was going to
happen all the investors that were
buying bitcoin and that's exactly what
happened it was up you know 400 it was 3
500 4 000 under 4 000 when we started
the pandemic and now we're sitting here
at 30 000 so it performed well in my
expectations to that i think now we're
trading in this range right because it's
become a risk asset closely correlated
with equities we'll see what happens
over time but at the end of the day
bitcoin aside everything else aside like
everyone needs to just look out for
themselves because now you're in the
position where maybe you got a three
percent race maybe you got a five
percent raise which would have been
considered net positive in another year
is now you're under water and you're
you're making less money than last year
relative to the goods and services uh
that you purchase every single year so i
think ultimately again
take care of yourself take care of your
family make sure you're educated about
these things get invested make sure you
can participate in the price increase in
assets so if what happens a year ago or
two years ago happens again you're able
to see that increase in prices because
at the end of the day inflation is the
silent killer it's a tax on everyone and
it can put you in a really bad financial
position if you're not prepared to to
benefit from it from an asset
appreciation step